yeah hello welcome to this video yeah I
want to address something and have to
tell us a little bit complicated way
because this is something that I wanted
to actually do at the start of the year
but then decided not to do but now
something has come up that made me do it
anyway okay what is it about it's about
comments on the videos mostly it's my
Blitz videos but also other videos I get
lots of feedback there actually and very
rarely respond to them to the messages
um and this is something that I wanted
to change for 2016 to try to answer all
questions and remarks for the videos
it's a bit of a work because there are
so many videos and sometimes they're
also older videos that get Commons and
so on but so this is was this what I
wanted to start doing in 2016 then
however I decided not to make the
announcement right at the start of the
year because at that moment yeah I was
had two plans to move to a new apartment
just like in two weeks or something it
should have been your happening like
next week or the week after that this is
what my plan originally and I didn't
want to kick off something yeah and then
being in the middle of a big hassle him
not being sure we have internet or
whatever and this is why I've decided
not to make that announcement or that
announcement it's not a big deal but I
just wanted to address that i will focus
on the on the comments more and today i
actually um the following came up
actually did answer a comment the
negative comment on a video today and
then there was this message that you can
see on the screen and this made me um
yeah do this video so I'm definitely
will be trying to answer to all them the
answer all questions or react to the
yeah decent comments to the video was
much more than I did before um
within within reason yeah and i will
move we had to a new place but it will
still take a couple of weeks so it's not
right around the corner as i as i am was
thinking um so i should have that time
to to to answer the question comments
and remarks them properly so feel
welcomed to pose questions for the
videos or or comments serve whatever
type as long as dean sins decent no no
trolling please or whatever and i will
try to answer them to the best of my
abilities and what my time permits I
will definitely focus on that a lot more
okay thanks for watching and feel
welcome to post more in future videos
thanks